[Musique]
bonjour ça va c'est comment l'ambiance
chez vous
alors venez vite nous retrouver vite
vite et on commence ça y est c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà du calme parce qu'aujourd'hui on
commence les chauffe-eau
notre émission avec un invité très
très célèbre
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et 2 7 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 derrière 1 2 3 4 -
5 6 7 8 et 1 2 3 pas bravo tout le monde
6 7 8 et 1 et 2 et 3 loin derrière 5 6 7
reste
génial bravo bravo à vous aussi
sache que pas de faire de ma culotte
alors
[Musique]
on va descendre
il y a toujours au même niveau vous
[Musique]
[Rires]
respirez respirez l'air frais de la
montagne
[Musique]
c'est agréable de courir dans cette
neige somptueuse
[Musique]
allez on respire un petit coup sur place
parce que sous la joie
allez encore
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
mais on se chauffe
ça fait un bien pour les poumons viens
là ça va
[Musique]
les bras le long du corps
on lâche un peu la tête un tout petit
peu sa tête voilà parfait comment
vous faites avec nous
et on reste droit
on monte un bras devant et on le monte
ce bras on le monte on le monte on le
monte et hop on le lâche Hello
[Applaudissements]
on lâche en arrière très doucement
et on tombe la tête maintenant sans
bouger tes épaules ouais bravo
encore
étirer plus loin pas très loin de
recommence avec le déo recommence avec
un solvant tout doucement le drame
doucement et on lâche respirer lâché et
l'autre bras
droit
ça fait de la dentiste
de chaque côté elle est
des épaules qui sont encore plus beaux
montrent les bras
voilà
sanguin maintenant viens sur moi encore
encore
la même chose
regardez Gilbert comme il se content
Gilbert et
on voit loin loin
[Applaudissements]
on ne se quitte pas c'est gym contact on
va poser plein de questions indiscrètes
à Bernard Tapie Bernard Tapie ah non
viens célèbre un homme d'affaires connu
pardon et par veau qui dirige des tas
d’état d'état de société mais avec une
pêche et une forme incroyable alors
comment faites-vous
comme ça ça m'a peut-être d'ailleurs
donné un état d'esprit qui diffère un
peu de certains de mes confrères et des
vôtres
parce que dans le sport on apprend on
apprend d'abord le fair-play on en
apprend très important on apprend à
apprécier à sa juste valeur le succès de
ses voisins car même lorsqu'on est
deuxième on applaudi pour le premier
c'est pas le cas dans notre métier
deuxièmement on apprend aussi que l'état
d'âme le mental l'intelligence tout ça
on peut pas le l'extraire de son corps
en fait il est le reflet de l'état de
santé de son corps et c'est vrai qu'on
est triste quand on est malade c'est
vrai qu'on est comme vous gay quand on
est en forme et donc je crois que il est
indispensable d'être physiquement bien
en forme si on veut être mentalement
bien disposé qu'est-ce que vous faites
Bernard je fais deux types de sport je
fais des sports de fonds le vélo puis je
fais des sports un peu violents et un
peu un peu tonique
j'étais surprise
c'est fantastique vous avez des régimes
j'ai obligatoirement
c'est une société qui s'occupe du bien
manger c'est ça qui est un paradoxe en
fait c'est que on n'a jamais mangé
autant et on n'a jamais souffert
d'autant de manque on ne manque de
vitamines on manque d'oligo-éléments
manque de fer de magnésium de choses
alors je crois qu'il faut réapprendre à
bien manger pas forcément
quantitativement mais qualitativement ça
c'est très pour ça il y a 40 ans que des
gens militent dans ce sens-là et c'est
d'apprendre aux gens leur expliquant que
il faut bien manger pour être bien dans
sa peau
alors beaucoup de bicyclettes et quoi
d'autre je fais la préparation full
contact qui est un sport tonique qui
permet de faire partir la pression vous
savez les trois quarts du temps on est
un peu bloqué on s'auto censure et on
n'ose pas faire exploser je crois plutôt
que de prendre une colère sur sa
secrétaire il vaut mieux taper sur
quelque chose et hurler Sarah au moment
où on en a besoin et la préparation au
Full Contact est une préparation comme
tous les sports de combat où on apprend
à en même temps qu'on donne un coup on
se libère d'une énergie qui est interne
ça évite d'avoir des scènes de ménages
et d'avoir des collaborateurs qui
souffrent
après vos réunions je fais ça à la nuit
c'est un sport de fond qui permet de
garder le souffle de pouvoir faire un
peu jogging comme ça tout en ayant une
capacité respiratoire intéressante et
puis je crois surtout que c'est un
moment donné on a on a forcément besoin
de ressembler un peu à ce que l'on à ce
que l'on est et je crois que je défends
à la fois par Bernard Hinault à la fois
par La Vie Claire à la fois par l'eau
qu'à la fois par Adams certaines idées
d'un nouveau management comme vous
l'avez fait vous dans votre métier je
veux dire que avant que vous exiez il y
avait des cours de gymnastique et vous
avez fait découvrir par à la fois
l'image que vous projetez la façon dont
vous abordez le problème vous avez fait
voir qu'on pouvait faire cette
gymnastique qui est emmerdante faut bien
le dire vous pouvez la faire en riant
vous pouvez la faire en s'amusant et
donc on en fait profiter on en fait
profiter pleinement
non c'est pas ça et moi c'est pareil si
je veux donner aux gens l'envie de
d'adhérer à ce que je ce que je réclame
et ce que je représente il faut que je
donne l'exemple moi-même donc je fume
pas je bois pas je suis heureux de faire
les choses comme vous voulez faire
[Musique]
ma première question tout à l'heure un
régime alimentaire ou pas du tout
comment on fait du million de choses
vous avoir entendu dire vous voulez une
crotte en chocolat et comment on sait
que je suis malade de chocolat je vous
ai dit pas vraiment il m'avait dit mais
si elle sort de la Vie Claire il y a
absolument tout ce qu'il faut dedans
pour ne pas grossir
votre âge on est fait pour pouvoir
manger une crotte de chocolat et par
conséquent si on la mange pas si on la
mange pas c'est quelque part il y a
quelque chose qui va pas bien
alors le vrai problème c'est est-ce
qu'on s'attaque en refusant certains
plaisirs d'une façon efficace au
problème ou est-ce qu'on se donne les
moyens de pouvoir faire des petites
bêtises comme ça moi je crois plutôt à
ça
tous les deux c'est exactement ce à quoi
je pense
en tout cas c'était très très gentil
d'être venu participer avec nous un
énorme bravo parce que c'est c'est vrai
que je sais à la fin il y a une douche
je suis venu parce qu'on m'a promis on
m'a promis je dirais la douche
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]